our next speaker is Professor Geronimo
who who is a French scientist and a
pioneer in the field of laser physics he
was born in June 1944 in Alda havilah in
the French Alps a town probably best
known for hosting the 1992 Winter
Olympics at least until now Moreau
started his career in physics at the
University of Grenoble ALP
getting his diploma in 1967 and moving
on to first Quebec and then Paris to
work on his doctoral thesis he received
his doctorate from Pierre and Marie
Curie University in Paris in 1973
Jacques who spent a large part of his
career in the United States in
particular at the laboratory from laser
energetics at the University of
Rochester New York
were one of his doctoral students as we
just heard was Donna Strickland together
the pair device the chair pose
amplification technique which today is
at the core of most high powered laser
facilities in the world in 1988 moo-hoo
joined the University of Michigan in Ann
Arbor where he founded the Center for
ultra-fast optical science he returned
to France in 2005 and became the
director of the laboratory of light
optics at the campus of Ecole
Polytechnique in Palace or a post which
he held on to 2008 moo-hoo is a
visionary aiming to create lasers with
unprecedented power he initiated the
multi petawatt apollon laser project in
France and coordinates the large
European extreme light infrastructure le
that will host even more powerful lasers
in Romania Hungary and the Czech
Republic
he is currently also the fuel director
of Isis the International Centre for
cetera what
and technology established in France in
2011 - among other things developed the
field of laser based particle physics
jacquimo who has been the recipient of
many prestigious prizes but I dare say
that this year's Nobel Prize must be the
icing on the cake with that I'd like to
invite professor moo-hoo to join me on
stage to give a talk staking out the
future of high intensity lasers
professor move
[Music]
well thank you very much for coming
friends colleagues former students and
so on well it's always a dangerous act
you know to act up behind Donna you know
anyway I'm going to try Donna it's also
a pleasure because there is many many of
my students in the audience students or
co-worker and for me it's very
refreshing is like you know when when we
had our group meetings you know at watch
Esther at Michigan and so on anyway so I
I'm going to tell you can be and can we
blow this picture little bit bigger yes
yes yes okay so I'm going ready to to
talk about my patient my patient about
extreme light so Donna gave you all the
background how to build these high
intensity lasers and so on you don't
need much more than that okay and so but
I'm going to tell you what you can do
with that okay because it's true that
it's only only recently but we had this
phenomenal in intensity available and so
there is many new discovery shall be
made okay so that's my patient all right
okay and so okay can maybe act okay I
can I can i yeah so everything like
Donna said everything and started from
with Ted Memon you know in nineteen
nineteen sixty and I'm sorry again the
doctor
yes and this one thing you know which
really strikes me about about light it's
a variety of things we can do okay
and as after ash Kingdom sorry showed
but what you can do you know first thing
is maybe you can slow down at homes and
it's a very very interesting phenomenon
we have seen with tweezers and so on and
this it doesn't okay so people you know
used it intensively very successfully
and trying to really use the light to
decelerate atoms and that led to the
field of quantum optics and called atoms
and you have Steve Chu in the first row
here which got a Nobel Prize with
cohen-tannoudji and also Bill Phillips
and so but LEDs this this flag but we
cannot really slow down the atoms to
very very small times velocity very
important it's another way to say that's
it's a way or so to make it atoms very
cold and which temperatures you know
which are I think the coldest
temperature we can produce now okay now
the other thing you can do and this is
what is exciting okay you can do just
the opposite you can accelerate
particles and and you can accelerate
particles like electrons for instance to
use a speed of light or very close to
the speed of light
okay and and this led really to a new
field which we call whole atavistic
optics I will tell you why we
relativistic optics in a minute we know
that light is relativistic of the
definition almost and and so that the
fact that we can now accelerate
particles to the speed of light then led
of course now to a venomous field you
know which deals with Alex accident of
physics nuclear physics cosmology non
your QED general relativity extra
dimension physics
you name it very large very large
feeling ok so I don't have to go to talk
about CPA we heard Donna st. you know of
course we because we are going to need
CPA of course to of course to accelerate
this particle and so on so I so CPA you
know we stretch the powers we amplify we
compress it and is and finally in order
to get their short pulses I'd like to
say one thing you know because it's a
very it was a completely novel concept
at the time and because everybody has
you seen was into dye lasers okay
especially the guys at the lab at that
time and and and here we came with with
Donna with solid-state lasers and so it
was it didn't grab the attention of many
people except I will say a couple of one
one for instant was Sunni Swanberg who
just visit in my lab because he had hint
that was very something special and also
I had the visit of people from the
Lawrence Livermore Laboratory Mike
Campbell and so on magazine in the
audience because he liked me they
understood immediately that it was
something important for for
power increasing the power of lasers
okay so now with this CPA technique what
is fascinating is we can really produce
very very high peak power and we are
going to use this high power I will show
you in a minute but just to give you a
sense the power of the peak power okay
if the light is in a paper in now it's a
new beta watt range okay which is about
a thousand times the total power of of
the world Ward grid so global will do it
okay but of course for femtosecond you
know 10-15 seconds but nevertheless it
extremely important and if you take now
this power you know B's petawatt power
and you focus it like Donna said over on
a on a spot size which is a weapon for
bright you cannot take off less than
that so typically on me micrometers or
so then you get a fabulous amount of
energy density on a very small spot and
this is of course you know lead is
leading to absolutely new application
just to give you an idea okay light like
the first picture showed and outer
ashing use short use and what fascinated
by you know really deliver pressure and
but when you are talking about pressure
light at a peda what level when you
focus light on a small submerged size
you can really produce pressures which
is correspond to about ten millions FL
tower on the top of your finger so it is
the largest pressure that you can
produce enough is but with light with
photons this is amazing so now this is
really the evolutions of intensity as a
function of years okay from 1960
from the 1960 where may man invented the
laser and the first five five lesson
let's first ten years new technique
improved the power and Mark you
switching more locking and then the the
intensity plateaued he plateaued because
like Donna said you know you are
damaging you if you go higher you are
damaging you your your laser inside you
know you you you damage I'm putting this
nice big track you know in your your
solid-state amplifier and you of course
makes you advisor of very unhappy right
Donna
and hardware yeah so anyway so in order
to prevent Donna making mistake I said
well if you know that's not the way to
do it let's do it this way okay let's
try it let's invent so CPA okay so she
would learn try damage word anymore
okay so so we we did she build it and
the CPA and then we we cool really now
we are not limited by by the breakdowns
of material loss and but and we could
easily climb up now the intensities and
now I mean since we 85 when we did it
the intensity have to say I think reason
obviously okay eight or nine orders of
magnitude okay and it going to go
further up okay with with lasers like up
alone but is being built lasers which
which is part of the Eloi
infrastructures you know and Gary and
and home mania and and and crag and so
on so he's going up and as we are going
up you know of course we are traversing
new regimes of physics so the first one
you know we and Donna said it you know
we we started to really observe
multiphoton ionization differently and
so on and and and and observe what she
was saying I know I saw we climbed up
with this as we climb up with the
intensity when we go into relativistic
optics why relativistic optics because
for the first times you know when you
have when you can see something this
means that you have been you have
electrons with which are agitated and
because they are agitated they are
really move producing light which are
coming and spiking your eyes okay so but
in a case of when you are passing 10 to
be 18 watt per square centimeter or so
then what happened is now the electrons
in your atoms move by a large amount and
move at the speed of light so the
electrons not to light but the electrons
are really moving at the speed of light
so so that's what's very interesting
regimes you know which leads to a lot of
fact and and so on so now of course if
you are pushing this is what we are
trying to do now if you are pushing the
intensity up you know like we are trying
to do with Apollo in the eye and so on
the end you you go into the you travel
atavistic regime and this time it is
because not only the electrons don't can
be moved at the speed of light but also
the protons protons which are massives
are 2,000 times the the mass of the
electron so the Imam as if but a 10 to
the 25 or so what Pascrell centimeters
they move
the speed of light and that's going to
be very important when finally if we
push even the intensity even higher and
I won't say exactly how we're going to
do that Jonathan we are indeed in the
audience and can we can talk about it
but so we go into this regime where
light interact with vacuum okay like my
friend position says we are boiling the
vacuum okay we are really separating the
particles real particles and the article
virtual particle in vacuum and this is
what we can do and at this regime which
is ten to the twenty eight twenty to
twenty nine what Pascal Santa materials
okay and basically what we do is we
materialize the value vacuum okay anyway
so moving right along okay again so now
just one thing if we go back to the
regime's you know a ten to fourteen and
so on you know then we can really use
this time to Saigon lasers so we don't
add for instance to two micro machines
to remove to a blade material very very
precisely the reason is femtosecond
laser are so good for that is because if
you are using for me number continuous
laser and you're shining the continuous
lasers on the on the on a target then
you are going finally to heat to all
volumes of the targets so you cannot
really micro machine with that now if
you are using pulses which are much
shorter nanosecond me nanosecond layton
nanosecond pulses which is for us is
infinity you know it's very long but you
do better be
because of course the heat doesn't have
the time to pop again between between
before the block is it's it's molten and
and then you have the femtosecond laser
where you come with a very very short
pulse and you deposit the energy and the
the temperature I mean the hate doesn't
have the time to propagate and you make
this very nice holes and it's a very
very precise way to really oblate
materials and this gives you some idea
you know of what we could do what you
can do in fact really easily now is
really what widely known was he highly
done everywhere and you can see that we
can really make holes and so on very
precisely
there is no collateral damage and Owens
very clean and very small okay
you see what we have feature of size
which is less than a micrometers you
know in in size and no damages so of
course now one beautiful way to use this
with this this laser is to is to do ice
surgery because after all eyes you know
is some magical tissue and also is not
the kind of things where you have to be
accurate with ice and so we thought
about that in fact we thought because we
had with little mishap happening in my
lab and this is one of one of my
students within the audience you know
God arranged the laser cutter laser in
his eyes and and immediately you know
for free to the students you know to the
hospital and they made the met after
largest who is also
here on Kurt and and so honkers look at
the detail do eyes both are here and say
wow this is very strange and yes you got
hit by the laser but it's strange and so
did you say what what is strange
well it's strange because the damage on
your retina is perfect so that
immediately you know of course you know
we had the University of Michigan you
know excited about it they put some
money in it and and and then we add but
started the field of femtosecond laser
which is a very very important field ok
so this is just to give you an idea what
we can do you know on on the on the
cornea we can use it all kinds of things
no we can on enough technology and so it
was very exciting
in fact so if you are I'm just show here
if you have 50 picosecond laser which is
long for us ok and if you have 300 10
toes are gone you can you see we can
really create this flap you know very
very nicely you know and and this is
being done you know now as I saw also a
few few of the largest here in the
audience and it's great so now I I had I
had a movie showing this creation of a
flap but I have to say that and some cup
after some comments people say well if
you show this this this movie maybe some
people are not going to stand it you
know for it because it's so I'm I'm not
going to show it okay and I will save
some time
but anyway if you want really to talk
about that here you have specialist
at least we at least we a specialist you
know on this thing here okay now let's
go back to my to my my hot nap here and
so as I said you so we were here for a
short while and now we are climbing up
as I said we are in this area right now
and what's exciting here
you know one we are which was like this
right yeah when we when you are in this
area of of you know 10 to the 20 and 25
weeks ago when you are shining the laser
over a very small size I mean sports
sports eyes like donna said wavelength
of light then you are producing with
amongest
intensities and you are producing
particles you know of any kind of
particles any kind of radiations with
very large with energy okay very freely
okay
it's amazing and so this is a we call a
universal source of eye energy particle
and radiations and this and this type of
course of work is being done at Lund you
know not there if one in Sweden
anyway and and if you are interested
people here okay so now what we are what
we want to do now is we are producing we
this was an idea from
Tajima and Dowson tashirojima a very
good friend of mine of a lot of people
also and the idea is this ID in 1979 he
said well you know looking at ducks or
whatever on the lake you know looking at
surf surfer and so on he said well maybe
we should use the same effect that is
being used by surfer in order really to
get particles moving so they they they
really wrote this very nice paper but of
course is 1979
so it's before 1985 so I didn't know
about this effect you know and Toshi
didn't know about the CPA okay so but
fortunately we had scientists at an
array of Naval Research Lab who we
really were able ready to solve the
potential to put the two concepts CPA
and laser Wakefield accelerations you
know together in order to accelerate
particles and this is what is going on
now in the many many laboratories in the
world you have lasers here and you shine
the laser on this gas jet and and you're
polishing a plasma you know which is a
plasma is a kind of a soup of electrons
and and and protons and so on
and you are creating this wave this
plasma waves where the electrons are
going to be trapped and dragged at the
speed of light you know by this wave
okay so this now it is really we were
talking last night with Olga this is
ready is the future for electron
accelerations and for is because we have
example problems in in high-energy
physics there are problems because you
have to build this huge accelerators
here you have the CERN accelerator or
LHC 27 kilometer in confluence yeah you
know and about 70 meters underground
so it is really of course it cost
enormous amount of in earth
of of money and now because for the the
next step the next next Collider is
going to be even bigger okay
and will cost in an affordable amount of
money so really it is very important
really to come to come and and with the
new technology and you think that if you
are ready we placing the technology use
right now in this in this case for
instance which is you were using high
def we can see you had microwave and so
on where you have the gradients is of
the order of less than 100 meters
Android I'm sorry Android MeV per meters
that's what is on weiu reverbs
2070 no matter but if you now are using
this novel techniques so josh is
Tajima idea to accelerate particles then
you could ready fit you know a CERN in
principle okay
turn on a football field okay so this is
pretty good okay but you know of course
we like with toshi to look ahead all the
time and so some people you know in the
agency's a difficulty to see that you
know and and but anyway this way we are
okay and so we like to look ahead and so
right now let me tell you but we can
produce now something like devices GeV
devices a centimeter of size okay now we
can produce up to 5 GeV but 5 GV is is
something like 10 centimeter in lab okay
and yes we could very maybe put turn on
the football field but could we - but
much better than that
and right now the reason is yes yes we
cool in fact I'm not putting your leg
here okay i weak already in fact next
the accelerator kind of TeV accelerator
on the fingertip and and by by doing
what okay
instead of using gas which has which has
a very low density of electrons then we
have to use black light to use solid
solid and so you have six order of
magnitude larger amount of electrons
okay because we are working also with
gas at low low density gas and and then
but you say wow
but I mean now light won't be able to
propagate through the solid at this very
high intensity and so so okay fine but
if we can if we can really develop high
I intensity x-ray now so but is instead
of visit working in a visible work in
the x-ray regime then with the x-rays
high intensity can penetrate into into
the salad and to produce this Wakefield
this is exactly what we are doing right
now you know it might be at at the ecole
polytechnique and in collaboration with
of course with tashirojima irvine and
also with some people from the eli okay
because we think Haley this is really
maybe the future trying to work with
laser Wakefield accelerations in in the
high-energy x-ray regime so we we have
we have ways to do that I don't have the
time to show it but
really I think it is really new new
avenue to do that now yeah I just a
quick reminder that the ISIS twee
phenomenal phenomenal facilities which
are being built by the European Union
and which are really in in Czech
Republic in anger and in Romania well
you have absolutely beautiful facilities
facility we are not well really doing
different things don't do three times or
something of course and the the end and
it's absolutely fabulous to have in few
years you know we will have them working
and welcoming large amount of users and
so an Arai for instance is very close to
get to the ten Peter what objective now
now you know what is this a big
application coming back to to societal
applications there's a very important
applications if you can produce beams of
particles let's suppose that you can put
we can really produce beams of protons
well you know protons therapy per exam
for cancer and so on is really the the
the really the therapy of choice okay
because the protons not like other
radiation of particles they don't burn
the tissue between bit between really
the the skin and the tumors you can
really address tumors almost you know
uniquely so you can deposit your proton
exactly in a tumor now also what is nice
about having these high intensity lasers
is you can make particles and these
particles
you know can be had your nucleotides and
and so on and you can use them you know
to implant these particles into into the
near the tumor or in the tumor of of the
patient also you can use these these
these I do isotopes and so on but you
know which in order to do all kind of
diagnostics and so on so this this CPA I
mean CPA high intensity or extremely
light in the extremely extreme light
intense intensity or lasers you know are
very very used but will be very useful
in in in medical world now just also
another egg applications but this is
dreaming what I'd like to do him anyway
so I did that all my life and made my
made my living with that and so anyway
so just one one really big problem we
have and this also together with Toshi
while working on it and by the way we're
not working because it's easy what's
going to we're working on it because
it's difficult okay
and what we want her to do is to
transmute transmute nuclear waste
because we have all nuclear energy it
may be the best candidate for the future
but you are still you are still you know
left with a lot of his junk dangerous
junk and and that's reason Toshi you
invented the terms now toilet science
it's time to do toilets and it's time to
to clean up what we have produced you
know producing energy and so on for our
living and so and so the idea now it was
is
is we have to find ways okay to mitigate
you know this nuclear waste in one way
will be maybe to transmute this this
this nuclear waste into a new new new
form of atoms which are not which
doesn't don't have this problem of
radioactivity and so what you have to do
is to change the making of the nucleus
okay of so far if you have a I if you
have a nucleus atoms a okay and you have
a isotope a and which is maybe lighter
active for a long time so that takes me
example of technician for instance and
which can be radioactive for 100,000 of
years then if you can if you can really
large a a neutrons because now we have
freedom we know we know that we can
produce any kind of particles you know
including neutrons we can produce
neutrons you know in in this in nucleus
when you are changing the isotope a into
an isotope B but this time it can have
ready now radioactivity time wheel is of
the order of seconds of course this is
most favorable case but so we will I try
to extend the concept you know to to of
course
so nuclear waste which are really
polluting our life right now
so and so by the way sometime you have
you're lucky and this isotope B becomes
isotope C and it's it's stable so it
doesn't emit anything
so in conclusion for me is extreme light
is capable of generating the largest
field the largest accelerations so
largest temperature and the larger
pressure just with flight is amazing
and it carries the best hope and
opportunity for the future of science
and technology so thank you very much
and I would like to add that you know we
are doing this very rich field right now
a field of extreme light but I think the
best is yet to come
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
so this concludes the physics lectures
for this year's Nobel Prize to 2018 I
would like to extend my profound thanks
again to three eminent speakers dr. SC
arvind ahktar Donna Strickland and dr.
moo-hoo for wonderful talks and having
said that I would finally like to invite
on the Bell laureates Donna Strickland
and Yahoo to come up on stage with me so
that you may congratulate them again to
this year's prize so please
[Applause]
[Music]